[Music]
thank you
very much with Joe Biden Anthony
Albanese this week to finalize the
details of the August nuclear submarine
pact Ike Freeman director of
indo-pacific at Green mantle advisory
firm writes in this week's magazine
about how Britain can do even more to
help combat China in the Pacific to
discuss he joins me now with Shashank
Joshi defense editor at The Economist
thank you for joining spectator TV this
week and just to begin the conversation
like how seriously should we take the
threat that China poses to Taiwan
I think the answer is very seriously
indeed China regards Taiwan as an
existential issue a question of
historical Justice and the resolution of
the Civil War that ended in 1949. China
is also afraid not unreasonably that
many people on Taiwan want to formalize
taiwan's de facto independence by
striking some sort of political
arrangement with the United States so
even if China is not planning an
outright invasion of Taiwan China needs
to dial up the military pressure on both
Taiwan and the United States to make
sure that they're deterred from doing
this
and Sasha when it comes to force um how
can we compare what China has
um not just to Taiwan because I think we
probably could work out the answer to
that
um but you know what allies would offer
such as America potentially if we did
you know face the potential standoff
I think the point is that the Gap is
been growing dramatically in the last 10
years or so
um particularly in the naval realm
China's Navy is the biggest in the world
between 2014 and 2018 It produced
vessels of more tonnage than the entire
Indian Navy or French Navy in total
which gives you a sense of just how
gargantuan that buildup IS and in some
areas notably in conventional missiles
but also air defense and certain other
areas
um we're seeing a significant Chinese
advantage and I think the challenge for
the Americans is
um how do they make sure that the air
bases they've traditionally had in
countries like Japan
um survive in the face of a big
onslaught of missiles so they're working
extremely hard to try and disperse those
forces as widely as possible and when
we're looking at obviously the big
announcement this week when it comes to
August
um you had you know I think two of the
original leaders at the time uh were not
August was first about and I have now
moved off and we haven't new leaders in
their place and but the agreement stays
strong and how's that do you think I'm
impacting all this in the sense it's a
big boost to Taiwan
I think that Arcus is more about
Australia's security and essential role
in the emerging architecture of
indo-pacific regional security than it
has about Taiwan Australia hasn't
committed in advance to participating in
any defensive exercises around Taiwan
nor have they committed to participating
in a war and I think that's probably
sensible for Australia's national
interests I think it's also a question
whether the UK would want to participate
it would depend on the context of how a
Taiwan War were to come about that said
I think it's definitely in the interest
of the United States Britain and
Australia to tighten their collaboration
in high-tech military uh high-tech
military development and in exercises
because the more tightly relevant
countries are in the region intertwined
in a vision for a secure and stable
indo-pacific
the more China is likely to be deterred
from causing trouble
is right but all I'd say is that I think
it is looking increasingly difficult
politically that Australia could stay
out of a war over Taiwan in the same way
that I think it would be increasingly
difficult for Japan to stay out of a war
um it's you know these navies are going
to be integrated America is going to be
increasingly reliant on um bomber bases
in the north of Australia submarine
ports in the west of Australia
um and the politics of turning around to
America in what would be the biggest war
since 1945 and saying sorry we're
sitting this one out to me that just
seems implausible for Europeans it's a
slightly different issue but even for us
I think we're going to find it
increasingly hard to say we're sitting
this one out
saw a situation where effectively I mean
Beijing uh have voiced their unhappiness
over their orcas announcement so you
have a situation where yes Taiwan itself
uh you know perhaps not you know it's
not a key part but the general sense uh
particularly perceived in China of
aggression towards China and does it
does I think probably have an effect in
making China think about its options
active uh you know they once hope that
Taiwan could be unified with the
mainland by peaceful means by economic
absorption trade ties economic ties
social ties what's actually happened is
Taiwanese people look at the fate of
Hong Kong
um and understand you know that's not
what we would like
um they they increasingly identify as
Taiwanese rather than Chinese in terms
of their identity and so that has pushed
the Chinese into a more radical position
but I think as much as we prepare for a
potential military conflict with China
and deter the Chinese there's also an
acute sense we also want to deter Taiwan
from anything rash we've been very lucky
to have a Taiwanese president for the
last several years who has been very
pragmatic and sensible who hasn't pushed
for anything radical anything that's
rocked the boat substantially that may
not be the case for the next 10 years
and so from an American perspective a
European perspective this isn't just
about deterring the Chinese it's also
about making sure the Taiwanese don't do
anything that dramatically changes their
status and their position across the
street
like on Taiwan could you just explain to
viewers what the Strategic significance
of Taiwan is particularly we're talking
about for example semiconductors
well Taiwan is essentially important to
the architecture of security in the
broader region and it starts with
geography itself general Douglas
MacArthur uh who commanded U.S forces in
the Pacific uh in World War II once
called Taiwan an Unsinkable aircraft
carrier in the first island chain if you
look at a map you can trace a line of
islands down from the Japanese
archipelago to Taiwan and the
Philippines down to Indonesia and
Australia the U.S concept for how to
maintain order in the Pacific since 1945
has been to maintain a network of bases
and relationships on those islands
because it's very hard to take an island
with an amphibious Invasion across an
ocean this represents a line of defense
that contains at first Russian and now
Chinese expansion outward it's also very
important from a naval point of view
because if you look on a map you may not
notice this but you have to look at a
topographic map it's actually very
difficult to get ships out from within
that first island chain right off of
China's coasts into the wider Waters of
the Pacific this is important for naval
ships and especially submarines if the
United States and Taiwan are working
together especially with Japan and the
Philippines they can largely contain the
Chinese Navy to just a hundred miles or
so off of its coasts but if China is
able to take control of Taiwan they can
project Naval power outward they can
threaten time they can threaten Japan
they can threaten to encircle and
blockade the Philippines and all of a
sudden they are able to project forces
much further into the Pacific even
threatening the United States Homeland
so that's the geographic reason why
Taiwan matters but Taiwan also matters
because it's become an essential
component of this integrated high-tech
global economy over 90 percent of the
world's Advanced semiconductors are made
in Taiwan and semiconductors make our
modern world run everything from Autos
to iPhones the United States obviously
can't let these facilities fall into
Chinese hands and in fact they've
communicated that if they're World War
uh the Americans would destroy these
facilities rather than lose control of
them but from China's perspective if the
United States is going to cut off their
access to these facilities anyway
it might be better to strike Taiwan just
to level the playing field so this is
the quandary the U.S needs to preserve
its competitive advantages in
collaboration with allies but the
various steps that it could take to
preserve those advantages could
incentivize China to strike
on semiconductors are we seeing Western
countries such as America take steps
when it comes to obviously having
self-sufficiency in terms of their own
supplies
they're certainly trying to achieve that
but it's extremely difficult because
this is a field in which the capital
investment necessary to produce
semiconductors particularly the the Fabs
that sort of produce these things
um is enormous absolutely enormous you
know staggering amounts the Technologies
are highly concentrated and so you know
for example in terms of uh lithography
one of the key techniques in the
production of semiconductors
um it's asml in the Netherlands which
has absolutely vital expertise so it
isn't just you know as if America has
everything it needs
um yes America has is you know it's past
laws trying to onshore some of this
production and there are very sound
reasons you don't want to depend for
your entire Economic Security and
semiconductor supply chain on a small
island that is within range of
um many thousands of Chinese missiles at
risk of invasion um but I have to say
that however much you invest in this
however however hard you try and however
much you talk to the South Koreans and
the Japanese and others and try and put
production facilities back in the United
States you're still going to be quite
dependent for the foreseeable future on
tsmc which is this Flagship Taiwanese
semiconductor firm and I think it raises
some fascinating questions you know
thinking more uh perhaps um in Macabre
fashion as to if there was an invasion
um what would the US Taiwan and others
do in terms of considering the
destruction of those facilities to avoid
them falling into the hands of the
Chinese government
and I I remember in previous interviews
when we talked about Ukraine for example
often Taiwan comes up and that
definitely was I think uh growing
consensus amongst uh you know some
experts on the issue they thought uh how
Russia having impacted by the invasion
of Ukraine would put china off actually
um trying to take Taiwan do you think
that's still seen as the case or
actually it does feel so alarm is
growing and you know up to this point
more so the Ukraine issue is complex and
it has had both pros and cons for China
on balance I think it's quite clear that
the the the cons outweigh the pros from
China's perspective uh the war in
Ukraine has shown that Western Unity is
possible it's shown that a military
force that is well funded that is
considered by many around the world to
be uh an extremely impressive fighting
force can collapse in operational
mismanagement and be held at Bay by a
much smaller adversary
from China's perspective I think this
should seriously call into question the
fighting ability of the people's
Liberation Army which let's face it
hasn't fought a major war since 1979 and
is mostly thinking about this Invasion
through studying in books so from
China's perspective there have been some
advantages for example Russia having
been largely cut off from the U.S
financial system having been forced
through this oil price cap scheme to
sell its oil at a much discounted price
has provided some economic advantages to
Chinese industry and it's put Russia in
a position of geostrategic submission
where it essentially has to listen to
China's uh requests more seriously and
potentially uh do what China asks Russia
would be an essential partner for China
in any Taiwan contingency and season
ping recognizes this which is why he
hasn't thrown Putin under the bus but
that said if I'm season paying uh the
the external environment that I face
today okay in terms of the unity of
purpose in my adversaries is much more
unfavorable than it was on February 23
2022.
and I think that is why Western powers
and not just the United States but many
of its allies and partners in Asia
recognize that the outcome of the
Ukraine war will be very important in
what it signals to China and that's one
of the reasons why the South Koreans the
Japanese and others uh have been working
more closely with NATO to try to make
sure that Western Unity is maintained
on that point
um I wondered I suppose on the flip side
is there a time incentive for China to
act in the next few years as opposed to
waiting longer
there's I think two things that work
here for the Chinese one of them is is
to do with their own National Power and
that's the consideration of the
so-called Peak China hypothesis has
China's economic growth uh peaked are
there serious structural problems in our
economy that may manifest over the next
10 years and uh a curve the very high
growth rates they've seen over the past
15 years
um and and also demographically are they
a substantial decline
um so that's one question you know is
there a shrinking window of opportunity
I certainly believe that one of the
reasons Vladimir Putin invaded Ukraine
last year was because not because he saw
uh necessarily thought it would be
entirely straightforward but because he
felt it would be increasingly difficult
over another five to ten years the flip
side of that is American strength um if
you look at American war games
um they all lots of them find that uh
America is at risk of losing a war over
Taiwan but what you do also find is if
they factor in
um additional Investments made in the
Pentagon particularly the procurement of
new types of weapon long-range drones
extra Munitions long-range anti-ship
missiles that this AIDS America's
ability to resist a Chinese Invasion but
none of that's going to happen for
another five five five plus years and so
from a Chinese perspective
um you know if you if you would you
rather fight the U.S force that exists
today
um without those long-range Munitions
without those New Concept of operations
and approaches that disperse their
forces across the Pacific or would you
rather fight the one in ten years time
that may have solved some of those
problems again I think that may
contribute to a Chinese sense of a
closing window of opportunity I don't
think that means that Chinese invasion
is likely I think it is actually less
likely than not in the next five years
but one can see how those factors will
shape the people's Liberation Army's
thinking and and I just finally I'd like
to know whether you agreed with that in
terms of less likely than not and
finally if we did add up there and what
do you think the chances are of a
conflict like this being contained
rather than ending up in a World War III
well look I think China has definitely
communicated that it's trying to
modernize its military with the goal of
gaining the capability of seizing Taiwan
by force that doesn't mean that they
intend to do it and that doesn't mean
that they have a deadline to do it
there's any number of reasons why China
would want to have that capability for
political reasons it gives them more
leverage over Taiwan and over the United
States to coerce them into getting the
outcomes that it wants by peaceful means
look there is a debate within the China
studies Community about
just what is the nature of China's
interest in Taiwan to what extent is it
emotional and symbolic and based on
Chinese history and the the fundamental
ontology of the Chinese Communist party
and to what extent is it opportunistic
and geopolitical and there's a
legitimate debate with reasonable
arguments on both sides but I think what
is undeniable is that any war with the
United States and certainly a war with
the United States and its Regional
allies would be devastating for China
would make it virtually impossible for
China to achieve all of its other
aspirations that it calls National
Rejuvenation which is essentially
building a fully advanced modern economy
uh in which the Chinese people are made
rich rich and influential on the world
stage so I think China is
disincentivized to provoke such a
conflict unless it thinks it's hand it's
is forced and while the peak China
hypothesis is probably true for
demographic reasons China's population
is peaking it's a economy slowing down
just because it faces a closing window
of opportunity doesn't mean it will
start a war if it thinks it's going to
lose
look I'm 29 years old I face a declining
window of opportunity to become an
Olympic figure skater but that doesn't
mean I'm going to succeed if I try uh
what we have to think about though as
not just as an American but also as a as
a network of allies and partners with a
stake and stability is how we manage
China's insecurity as it Peaks and
begins to decline
China is very afraid that the United
States and Taiwan in the future will
exploit China's weakness in order to
change the status quo fundamentally and
lock in Taiwan Independence and so at
the same time as we work to deter China
we also need to reassure China that if
they don't initiate a conflict that we
will respect their red lines and that we
can continue to maintain a status quo
that is acceptable to them over the
longer term
[Music]
thank you